kim kardashian and kanye west may be
divorcing when i divorced him you have
to know it came down to just one thing
his personality but there's still a
whole lot of love and respect between
the former couple
i'm married the best rapper of all time
a talented legit genius who gave me four
incredible kids
in a new profile for wsj magazine's
november issue the 41 year old reality
star opens up about the rapper and his
continued involvement in her
professional life she tells the mag
quote he has a piece of skims himself
and gives the team inspiration but also
information kim says kanye really enjoys
the entire process so much so that it
left quite an impression on her she pays
him a huge compliment saying quote kanye
will always be the most inspirational
person to me
he's just the most genuine person
so how exactly does the grammy winner
inspire the skims founder keep things
simple kim explains quote he expressed
that there were too many branding
situations he's always super simple i
really wanted to condense my beauty
brands i wanted one place one website
where everything can live
i always know his heart well seems like
the mom of four definitely took that
note about simplicity to heart this year
at least when it comes to her fashion
choices kim has turned heads on several
occasions recently for her unique looks
designed by balenciaga a label kanye
recently collaborated with
from these monochromatic looks to her
unexpected ensemble at the 2021 med gala
seems like kim is really enjoying this
style shift but she says it's over quote
i had a few moments i had some fun but
i'm back to minimalism
that's all i really need
it's definitely admirable seeing how kim
and kanye are collaborating and
co-parenting nearly nine months after
the beauty mogul filed for divorce
despite rumors of a potential
reconciliation a source told e.t earlier
this month that kim yeh is in fact
moving forward with a permanent split
adding that they're in a good place but
they are not getting back together the
source also adds that the yeezy designer
agreed to give kim their hidden hills
estate because it's close to her family
and they didn't want to uproot their
four kids north saint chicago and salm
from their routine quote kanye has told
friends he'd give kim whatever she wants
as he loves her and knows he'll be fine
financially
[Music]
you